are you smarter than a politician the
answer is yes if you were among the
millions of students who thanks to the
charity run by this high school teacher
get to watch my videos in class actually
not all the videos are mine but the
charities called stossel in the
classroom because I offer free videos to
any teacher who wants video teaching
aids for courses in economics government
critical thinking and current events
watching and discussing the videos gives
kids new perspective on things but the
people that accept welfare the over time
they lose the incentive to work every
year we hold an essay contest winners
get money plus a free trip for them and
their teacher to visit us here in New
York City
this year's contest invited students to
write about price gouging a practice
hated by the media and most politicians
Jeff Sessions and the president knighted
States will not tolerate gouging gouging
becomes an issue every hurricane season
because after storms some merchants
raise prices they've taken advantage of
us that leads politicians to pass laws
that say during a state of emergency
you cannot substantially raise prices
whether it's a hotel room fuel
commodities such as water generators you
cannot raise prices substantially and
that's what these bad people are doing
fortunately our students get to hear a
Nobel Prize winning economist give the
other side of the argument the gougers
deserve a medal the gougers our heroes
said Milton Friedman because they take
risks to bring in goods that people
desperately need after Hurricane Katrina
one so called Goucher was John sheperson
watching news reports about Katrina he
learned that people desperately needed
things
my wife just got out of the hospital
she's very sick then we need a generator
so John bought 19 generators put them in
a rented u-haul and drove it 600 miles -
part of Mississippi which had no
electricity five million people in this
region are without power John offered to
sell as generators for twice what he
paid for
people were eager to buy people were
excited we had a product they needed but
Mississippi police wouldn't let John
sell them they called that price gouging
instead they confiscated his generators
and locked John up in this Jail so did
the public benefit No somebody needs to
bring these products to people when
they're hard disasters and emergencies
and and this is gonna be one person
that's not going to be there that
they've took out of the equation
students who entered our video essay
contest expanded on that point in modern
day you see countries like Venezuela
suffer from the fact that their
governments continue to place price
controls on all items 17 year-old
Annalise guffawed of Raleigh North
Carolina submitted this video and won
our high school award 34 the 50 US
states have laws against price gouging
as I did more and more research I was
like okay maybe price gouging isn't such
a bad thing
Erica Lewis of Towson University won the
college level category sellers are able
to earn more profit and buyers are
capable of getting the supplies they
desperately need actually the price
calendars are the moral ones 17 year old
Maggie her on search of Grove City
Pennsylvania won her high school essay
contest you just look at the economics
the most people are helped if you keep
the government out of it when people
hear price gouging they think Oh gouging
this awful thing that you'd think of but
it really is kind of just another name
for supply and demand wisdom from
students helped to look at all sides of
the issue by teachers who use our videos
next year's essay contest will be
announced soon
check out SITC org for the latest
information